Dana's not wrong on this sometimes it
sucks how can you not like Francis and
Gano dude Amazing Story Amazing Story
But at the end of the day
if you're a business you cannot care
about people's feelings and their
background in their story it does not
matter
what matters is what's putting butts in
the seat what's on pay-per-view tickets
Francis is not that guy this isn't me
hating on Francis or hating on the bfl
or sucking Dana off has nothing to do
with that this is very black and white
Dana's right
he's 100 right now I'm not saying he
can't pay the guys more that's not the
point of this conversation of course you
can pay more that's a whole different
conversation for the current model
Francis does not benefit does not work
under their model that's all this is